this is the second year that CMU is
hosting the Special Olympics western
sectional games we're going to be having
here at CMU it's an all day event we
have over 600 special athletes coming to
our university or taking this event
which includes basketball competition
golf swimming tennis field and track
it's an all day event we have over 400
of our own community members students
faculty and staff they're going to be
here and help make this event happen at
CMU Mike's bitter partisan Vincent's we
started it here we do a lot of Special
Olympic events together a lot of
fundraising together huh yeah right yep
you ready to come you I should stop yeah
what's your event you did ask you
don't play all back Kardashians all but
I need when they're Penn State here
first in the next round and then the
next one is Penn State that's assets of
state games right after the song that's
later yeah and I know a big part of why
you like Special Olympics is because of
the basketball but what else you can
think of all the friends you may yeah
I'm the friendship we cumin and make
friends like cough and tighter good and
he's a good friend of your girlfriend
yeah and my items is Robert own you
before best poem I'm fine all right but
what happened a when we're in the gym
and I bet you what money that you would
do what makes a three how much I bet you
can did you do it yes did I give you the
ten dollars yes what are you gonna do
with the ten dollars on saving it then I
application very good yeah we were
asking for as many volunteers as we can
get but we also want people just to come
and be a fan come on in come on down or
here all day long support the athletes
and I tell people you'll come here
you'll be humbled and rejuvenated by the
enthusiasm not only for their sports but
for white that you will see in these two
athletes and then you might make a good
friend for life too so come on down and
join
[Music]
and
what do you think about this guy over
here and I k Murat some oh good huh for
an older men I'd all right there or is
he good guy
you